[Music]
[Music]
well i'm a theoretical physicist and the
world of
physics
particularly
quantum physics and uh
general relativity theory of gravitation
black holes big bang and so on they're
just full of abstract concepts and so
people really do get the wrong end of
the stick the one that sort of drives me
crazy uh is about the expanding universe
and the big bang
the big bang as far as we know is the
origin of time itself people always want
to say well what happened before the big
bang and the answer is nothing
and then they can't understand how there
can be nothing they think was empty
space but no it's not we're not talking
about empty space we're talking about no
space no time no thing and the expanding
universe people think well what's it
expanding into
and the answer again is nothing the
whole universe is expanding space space
is expanding uh maybe the space is
infinite uh it doesn't have to expand
into anything it is space that's
expanding so these things are really
very difficult people have terrible
misconceptions
uh they want to know with the big bang
uh well where did it happen you know was
it over there where's the center of the
universe where it was the edge of the
universe as far as we know there's no
center
and no edge and so these are just
misconceptions it's very very difficult
for
non-physicists
to actually
wrap their heads around these ideas
[Music]
well i've been fortunate in living
through the golden age of cosmology
because when i was a student which was
many decades ago
in in london in the swinging six sixes
maybe some of our viewers remember the
swinging success uh it was often said
well there's speculation there's
speculation squared and then there's
cosmology uh it really wasn't more than
a description of the universe it didn't
have much of a sort of theoretical basis
but all that changed uh in the late
1960s with the discovery of the fading
afterglow the big bang the heat
radiation that comes to us pretty much
undisturbed since a very very early time
just after the big bang and
over the decades by mining data from
that information using satellites it's
been possible to reconstruct a history
of the universe in extraordinary detail
and i've been very privileged to be part
of that program i worked in cosmology
most of my career
and our understanding of
how the big bang went bang and what
happened not just
in the first
few years
but in the first split second
after the big bang our understanding of
that has advanced enormously so we can
now be fairly confident we understand
the universe back to about a trillionth
of a second
after the big bang
because we can directly in the lab
recreate the conditions that prevailed a
trillionth of a second after the big
bang going before that we have to use
theory but the theory
and the observations from this fading
afterglow match very well and so it's
really exciting that it's gone from this
sort of sleepy backwater of science to a
mainstream endeavor
[Music]
[Music]
right
well things have changed so i keep
alluding to
when i was a student i suppose that's
what happens when you get old um but
when i was a student it was generally
thought either that you couldn't say
anything at all about the big bang it
was an event without a cause it was
beyond the scope of science or the
prevailing view was that it was the
origin of space and time that there was
no epoch before the big bang i think
stephen hawking expressed it very well
he said asking what happened before the
big bang is like asking what lies north
of the north pole the answer is of
course nothing but that doesn't mean
there's some mysterious land of nothing
north of the north pole there ain't no
such place as north of the north pole
and in the same way there ain't no such
time as before the big bang and people
find that very mysterious until i point
out that saint augustine of hippo in the
5th century
said that the world was made with time
and not in time that was a remark made
on theological grounds on the basis
that he didn't like the idea of a god
who is within the stream of time
sitting there for all eternity and then
on a whim making universe at some
particular moment it's good to have a
universe why didn't god make that
universe an infinite time ago uh so
augustine wanted time itself to begin
with the universe
that sort of shifted a bit in about the
mid 80s
and now the pendulum seems to have swung
the other way that the big bang
was just one of an infinite number of
bangs scattered throughout space and
time uh we can talk about our universe
originating from our big bang but
there'll be other bangs
and
the assemblage of all these banks
uh all these universes is eternal and so
that's the fashionable view that there
was no ultimate beginning or end of this
infinite assemblage of universes but our
particular universe had its origin in a
big bang it's got a birth
a life cycle and maybe a death
eventually
but the bigger system goes on forever so
it is then meaningful to talk about well
if the big bang was just as a local
affair
uh um by local i mean uh you know maybe
trillions and trillions of light years
across but still finite
then we could talk about what preceded
it
but in terms of
you know theory versus experiment there
are lots of theories
i
follow all of these uh speculations but
it's just mathematics in terms of is
there any observational evidence of what
happened before the big bang or anything
happening before the big bang well
there's some hints
in this
cosmic background radiation this fading
afterglow uh of of the big bang
um and so uh
based on that notion uh i uh written a
book called
what's eating the universe uh which
looks at some of those ideas that maybe
our universe has been gobbled up by
another one or has collided with another
one
and that's an idea put forward by laura
masini houston
[Music]
i do my level best
to communicate in plain language i avoid
using any equations because they seem to
frighten people
i talk about the
language of mathematics the poetry of
mathematics but don't actually
do any
and
in terms of understanding the concepts
yes of course i always draw upon uh well
can i remember how i first wrapped my
head around this uh particular idea
i make a lot of use of analogies and
metaphors i think can be really helpful
at the end of the day it is a somewhat
frustrating business because i think i
can get people excited by science and
give them sort of flavor and talk about
the type of problems and the outstanding
mysteries and things like that people
will often go away
thinking well they've grasped it but the
truth is uh that if if you want to
understand you know what's going on
inside an atom or inside a black hole or
something like that
you really have to
resort to mathematics and so
there's this sort of dance that goes on
of having to glide around
what really only makes sense
in
mathematical terms i have to do that
simply because there's a dictum that
every extra equation you put in a book
harvest the readership
uh my my wife who is a science
communicator ex bbc uh radio
producer uh reads all the stuff
i write in very great detail and she'll
often say to me but i you know you've
explained this uh term uh
or this concept about
how the universe is expanding or the
speed of light or why we can't see
beyond a certain distance but
you know how can that be because you've
also said something else uh and i always
say well look let me let me just draw
the graph or write down the equation and
she says well that's no good
because
i don't understand the mathematics so
that's no help so i i think all science
popularizes in physical science there's
a face for this problem it's okay in
biology you can you can talk about a
ghost or a giraffe or something like
that everyone knows what you mean
and even if you talk about dna
and
translation of dna into proteins or
something it's uh it's pretty
straightforward but things like quantum
mechanics so really it's only with a
mathematical framework that you can
fully understand it
[Music]
i suppose
as a physicist i have always been
baffled by life and the nature of life
the physics of living matter and even
more by mind by consciousness uh what's
going on up here uh that gives us uh
this sensation of that i myself and i'm
looking out at a world and i can
understand there's a world out there but
there's an inner world in here of
thoughts and feelings and sensations
and
we haven't really joined these two
worlds together the world of physics the
world of matter of stuff of hardware and
this inner world of feelings and
emotions and when we get into areas like
right and wrong
good and bad ethics religion all of
these things
then it's at the opposite end of the
spectrum so just you know molecules
banging around with the
forces
and
there really is a big division
in science between those who think uh oh
well in the end we will have a full
explanation of how everything works
according to the fundamental forces of
nature uh down at the molecular level
that's often called the
the fallacy of nothing buttery
that the i'm talking to you now there's
nothing but a moving mound of atoms
talking to another moving mound of atoms
and
at the end of the day that's all there
is to it uh and
all of human value and ethical things
and so on get swept aside but that
leaves us in a terrible place
because we have to design a society
where we have some sort of broad
agreement on on what is right and wrong
what is ethical or unethical there has
to be some sort of morality uh and if
you think well ultimately everything
just stems from the laws of physics
then it seems to make a bit of a mockery
of that and so i'm very concerned as we
think about artificial intelligence for
example we're going to try to embed
human values
in computers and other devices which may
be super smart
and they may design their own successes
and their successes and so on
how can we embed human values in
perpetuity
and are there such things as
fundamental values that are built into
the scientific picture of the universe
or is it all just relative is it just
human beings making out what's
convenient for themselves i don't know
the answers to these things but i do
feel that
we're reaching a point in society where
science has learned so much that these
sorts of issues are coming to the fore
and i uh
the simple prescriptions i have from my
background in physics just don't work
when we apply them to things like
values and ethics
[Music]
well the great thing about being a
physicist is that physics is a mature
discipline it's sort of like roughly 300
years old and we've learned an awful lot
of things about the universe we have a
very good understanding
of atoms molecules matter radiation
gravitation uh the expanding universe
the lot you might think well we you know
we've
we've done everything there's nothing
left to do but goodness me there is
there's a whole list of mysteries we
mentioned one of them what happened
before the big bang and something eating
the universe
and there's a whole list of things which
i'm outlining in my new book uh and so
there's a lot left to do so any young
people watching this or thinking about a
career a career in science is just
anyway but in something like fundamental
physics um but we need you there are
still mysteries out there there are
still unanswered problems
and it's absolutely wonderfully
fulfilling career to enter into this
wonderland of concepts and ideas and
dare i say mathematics and
come to understand things that have been
mysterious for generations
you might be the first person to finally
grasp something that has had the rest of
humanity stopped
so it's an invitation for young people
to come into science
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
you